[Music]
is anyone hungry yes starving i'm on it
i'm just going to wait until we get home
where the food isn't decomposing well la
i didn't realize i was with a bunch of
sophisticates
families can come in all shapes and
sizes that's why i also feature having
some two-legged children join them roll
it imagine me and our future children
frolicking
this is fun i'm speeding up a little i'm
speeding up quite a bit
i think he's getting the hang of it
tommy no those are mr mcgregor's i swear
if it wasn't for me peter just leave my
tomatoes alone you have everything else
honestly my kids will be so much better
behaved go easy on him as soon as they
have a baby
we're done for
maybe we're better off without them
don't stare at the scenery rushing by
look at a fixed point on the horizon and
just lock your eyes onto that
[Music]
i love this place
what's for lunch there's a magical place
with the ripest radishes the sweetest
corn it's called
the farmer's market and if you want an
overpriced gift that will never be used
they sell lavender scented bath bombs
this sounds a bit dodgy i would never
put you in danger i promise
okay i can't promise we're gonna go and
rob this place are you in are you out
we're in
run
let them go my family's in trouble
and i'm gonna get them back
the other rabbits were taken and the pig
and the hedgehog and the badger
let's go get the others
why are you even helping me
that's what a dad does
[Applause]
[Music]
oh no cottontail just discovered sugar
we had a good run
i'm gonna live forever
tell you
in days of yore there were two warriors
i kill for a spicy tuna roll right about
now
get yourself a little something the
brothers grew apart and a new age began
in the middle edge dad is uncle 10
coming for christmas this year sweetie
sometimes you just grow apart
you can't solve everything with money
but you can't you haven't changed at all
still a big baby suck it ted you suck
out of my face excuse me
i hate to interrupt i mean it's a
riveting conversation but why don't you
suck it
she can talk a lot
i'm in the family business and now you
work for me boomers
baby corp developed a new formula that
can turn a grown up back into a baby for
48 hours
you want me to be a baby again
[Music]
[Applause]
yep there's the awkward stage
ew baby corp will offer a full memory
wipe following this experience
so what's the crisis an evil genius is
teaching kids to be very bad bad babies
welcome to the baby evolution
we're gonna need a disguise to go
undercover
what have you done to me yeah no really
going sailing oh no
[Music]
thanks for always having my back you're
my brother we always stick together
because that's what families do
we need to hurry before the formula
wears off
what the [ __ ]
aren't you a cutie in that little karate
outfit
oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh
i'm sure this isn't something money
can't solve
what the fudge
[Music]
katie used to be my little buddy
go on nature hikes skip rocks
are you excited for camp don't make me
go we used to be so connected hey dad
smile you know you could experience
things a whole lot better without that
camera that this is how i experience
things
yes tomorrow i'm finally leaving for
college but in the meantime i made you
guys this goodbye video you know what
this is our last night together how
about we make ten seconds a family eye
contact starting put your phone down now
no you're allowed to blink it's just eye
contact oh finally no screens at the
table linda why are you kicking me i
don't understand i'm just gonna look
i'll watch it dad it's too late look i
wanna watch it
uh dad this is exactly why i'm excited
to leave tomorrow katie i know you can
fix this
why do you need all that to take me to
the airport i canceled your plane ticket
to college we are gonna drive you to
school on a cross-country road trip as a
family
behold
and now i present trekking rick mitchell
to kiss me dang it kitty dang it katie
hey dad can you check the trunk yeah
sure dang it katie hey kids there's
supposed to be some great hugs around
here
we hear a pound about to drop our
biggest invention yet meet the helper
bot we promise you they will never ever
turn even
mom what is that
greetings humans
technology rising up
sayonara
robots roaming the streets what is this
strange creature
dog pig dog pig dog loaf of bread
the beetroots have always been weird
no time to wash your hands don't worry i
never do that's what makes us great
that's my girl
then we just might be weird enough to
save the world
all right hands in
oh he licked my tongue
[Music]
we can go anywhere
do anything
we just gotta stick together
we underdogs have to look out for each
other right underdogs
this is gonna be the best summer ever
[Music]
see the whole world together
[Music]
it'll be amazing
but there's just one thing
wait did you see that no one can find
out
[Music]
where did you boys say you were from
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey where you going i thought we were
going fishing
you're welcome
[Music]
a sequel how original
[Music]
after a lifetime of being the world's
most famous enemies
[Music]
tom and jerry are about to start over
cause that's what friends are supposed
to do
in the big city
this hotel has been host to four
presidents three popes two kings and
we're about to host the wedding of the
century
do you think you're qualified to take on
this position i shine under pressure
like a diamond or rihanna
one other thing
we have a mouse problem with the what
now
i'll catch it sir everybody gonna shine
like this don't even gotta try oh wow
this is so detailed
we could hire an exterminator or we can
leverage millions of years of predatory
evolution
[Music]
if a picture of these mouse is tweeted
out to insta book face or ticky talk we
will be ruined
no sir that's not gonna happen that
rodent is toast
[Music]
i will not let this hotel be ruined by a
cat in a mouth
i think i might have just pulled this
off
[Music]
all right guys remember what we're
looking for and don't trust anyone
hey
baby
where are your parents
hey uh who's baby
really a con baby
[Music]
impressive we could use someone like you
let's catch you up
my name is raya our lands have been at
war for as long as we can remember our
people never see eye to eye
my daughter i believe our people can
come together again but someone has to
take the first step now in order to
restore peace we must find the last
dragon
i wish to join this fellowship of
trickery
let's go
we'll have to watch our backs
we're not the only ones looking
six years of searching
please let this be it
we really need your help ah i'm gonna be
real with you i'm not like the best
dragon have you ever done like a group
project but there's like that one kid
who didn't pitch in as much but still
ended up with the same grave
uh we're doomed
you and the dragon are coming with me
hmm my sword here says we're not
the world's broken
you can't trust anyone
maybe it's broken because you don't
trust anyone
you just have to take the first step
i just shave changed dragons can do that
look how close my butt is to my head
it's gonna make digestion so much faster
in theaters or ordered on disney plus
with premier access march 5th
[Music]
so what are you doing out here
there is a legend
in the jungles of the amazon
of a tree that heals all it could change
the world
but if it gets into the wrong hands
he could awaken a great evil
i believe that the legend is real and
i'm gonna find it what you want when i
do just imagine the lives that could be
saved
i've been looking for this tree longer
than anybody
i've tracked the legend to every village
every island nothing you're searching
for something that can't be found
but you've never had the key
let's do something that's safe let's go
see some elephants there are no
elephants in the amazon and i don't even
like elephants lady everybody likes
elephants
know this about the jungle
everything that you see wants to kill
you and can
careful they could smell fear
i am not afraid
oh my gosh
who brings a submarine to the amazon
[Music]
good night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
frank get it hold on come on i got it
i don't got it no no no no no no
just leave me alone that was a disaster
didn't go the way i planned
[Music]
[Music]
are you ready
this is the main event
let's
who wants a selfie
tentacular i've got your whole life
story tattooed on my body
yeah
in a long history of monster wrestling
there has never been a champion quite
like centennial fans around the world
are asking is there a challenger out
there with the hunger
the drive
the discipline to become the next
ugh
champion
all right i think that's enough for
today
steve might not look like much but there
is a champion monster inside of him did
he eat
thank you that felt great
we seriously need to work on strength
and endurance fortunately i know just
the thing
what
yeah that's gonna be a hard no for me
[Music]
do it again
[Music]
you got it
oh boy oh this is my nightmare
you are not going to get away with that
good night good night dad
where am i gaff you're behind your dream
stage it's completely off limits for all
dreamers
the dream stages are real wow
you can actually change people through
their dreams
why did they have to move in with us
don't you want to be a real family again
[Music]
there's literally no insta here omg omg
my new stepsis come on selfie time
jenny has more than a thousand followers
that is so gross tomorrow i'll make sure
my mom removes that thing i always get
what i want
three two one don't wake me up she wants
to put my hamster in an animal shelter
maybe i could tinker a tiny little bit
with her dream
[Music]
[Music]
i mean how am i supposed to whack in
this heat these conditions
[Music]
get up here you big lump no one must
know there are dragons in the valley
fire drake stay out of trouble
what was that
humans i've always told you they're the
worst what will they do when they find
them
the rim of heaven huh
a paradise for dragons we could go there
and lead everyone to safety how are you
planning to get that i've got wings
haven't i
inspired by cornelia funka's
best-selling book so genius where do we
start
hi
[Music]
you're him yeah
climb aboard dragon rider
[Music]
golf and easy dragons
i just saw a juicy silver dragon hunger
for a silver dragon let's get out of
here at us both roaring
many have searched but no one has found
the rim of heaven who's hungry now's not
the time for refreshments i'm trying to
be mystical
it was an arranged marriage you are much
more than you think you are follow your
heart and the truth will come to you
ready
ready
join a gang of unlikely friends
on a magical quest you want some of this
you were a thai guy
they're going to be japanese
dragon rider
so we are two next partners
coming soon
scoob do you realize where we are no
look around man the clean modern
aesthetic the cool blue color palette
we're in mikey falcon fury did you say
ikea nope i said falcon terry just like
you
oh whoa shaggy and scooby were taken
yeah
this blue light came down from the sky
and beamed them up
i can't
i can't breathe i'd have to assume that
if they were with their friends they
wouldn't have been kidnapped okay can
you skip the emotional punishment
what was some guy almost scooby and
shaggy i don't know but i'd like to
shake the hand of whoever created this
and then you know throw that hand in
prison for trying to kill our friends
[Applause]
this mangy stray is coming with me he's
not a stray okay then what's his name
his name's scooby middle name doobie
last name
dude
[Music]
gentlemen welcome aboard
this isn't about some guy in a rubber
mask i would have gotten away with this
if it weren't for you medley
this is about one of us
[Music]
welcome to the falcon fury
hang on hang on turn on the lights where
are my balloons dede when i say falcon
fury that's supposed to cue the balloons
oh great great timing
you might want to buckle up
[Music]
scooby dooby doo
maybe this can lead us to our culprit
kinkies apparently he's been stealing
netflix by using his mother's account
that is not fair for the rest of us who
have to pay for netflix you have to pay
for netflix here we go
if you want you can pull over and drop
us off here
i guess our new movie is an origin story
every hero should have one i want the
rock to play me
never gonna happen
[Music]
what are you doing here in somerville
anyway honestly my mom won't say it but
we're completely broke
and the only thing that's left in our
name
[Music]
is this creepy old farmhouse our
grandfather left us in the middle of
nowhere
why'd you bring me up here entertainment
value
what is that i don't know
somehow a town that isn't anywhere near
a tectonic plate that has no fault lines
no fracking no loud music even
is shaking on a daily basis
under the dining table now
hey remember that one summer we died on
our table
i found this in my living room
killer replica
a replica of what
a ghost trap
hasn't been a ghost sighting in 30 years
new york in the 80s it's like the
walking dead
your dad never mentioned this to you
it's just my
mom my grandfather died
my mom says we're just here to pick
through the rebel of his life
wait a minute
[Music]
who are you
[Music]
call it fate
[Music]
call it lock
call it karma
i believe that everything happens for a
reason
come on darling
it has a gunner seat
[Music]
who is coming to my birthday party what
about rapunzel and don't tell me she's
getting her hair done nope writing
something called a book sleeping beauty
says she has insomnia princess cruise
that's a ship sir princess leia she's a
general man i demand glorious guests
then may i suggest inviting this young
lady
finally this horrible crown gets it
once upon a time delivered a princess
named snow white
but this fairy tale is about to get a
whole new twist
we need to find the most beautifulest
woman to kiss us and reverse the curse
[Music]
oh my gosh what what happened to me i
mean my face and my waist um is that
really what i look like in the mirror i
think i hit her too hard
your power has drained you i don't have
much time prince find her
are they after you it's my shoes yeah
they're magical attention idiots draws
oh it's that loser prince average ah voo
raj ah please charge
featuring the voices of chloe grace
morris sam claflin gina gershon and
patrick warburton i can't wait for you
to see the real me i like you just as
you
are oh you had a thing on your cheek
your true self you're amazing on the
outside and the inside is the fairest of
them all
this is where your fairy tale ends
[Music]
i shall
return on tuesday no wait check my
calendar
thursday you've got to be kidding me red
shoes and the seven dwarves
[Music]
it's been 147 days since the great flood
and only the animals lucky enough to
find a place on the ark have survived
[Music]
it hasn't been easy with no sign of land
what's this one same as yesterday
this one it's a burned pot of that one
this is all the food we have left huh i
need to make this food go a long long
way
dave where are the kids
[Music]
i built this colony to keep nestorium
safe
from me dating beasts things are
different now they're the truths on the
ark
the ark it's landed oh boy here we go
shouldn't we help them what do you think
they'll be eating when the food runs out
rocks no not rocks
you
you want us to go running into the jaws
of your carnivorous friends if our time
on the ark has taught us anything and
never ever get into a tickle fight with
a hippo no dave it has taught us that it
is possible for us animals to put our
differences aside
[Music]
2x2 overboard
hey guys what did i miss only in cinemas
this october
remember what we talked about i don't
want to get a call from this new school
telling us that you've developed some
sort of chicken expanding rape
[Applause]
sorry about that
welcome to constant academy look at this
place from the creators of the nut job 2
and escape from planet earth i'd like to
introduce you to danny dawkins
thanks a lot genius danny dawkins is
about to discover
[Music]
another world
well that was monumental
who are you i guess you can call me
mothman what kind of alien language is
that
there are monsters everywhere
is getting bigger that means bigger
monsters can come out how much bigger
can they get
[Music]
get ready to fight the monsters
save the school if anyone can stop these
things it's the smartest kids in the
world
and be a hero
you okay i admit that plan wasn't fully
thought out featuring the voices of
jamie bell and ruby rose let's do this
monster zone
you didn't see nothing
[Music]
i love my life
i love you so much gary
i'll never forget the day we met
hello little snail what's your name gary
huh do you want to be friends
me too
i'm home
gary
bear
gary oh gary have you seen gary no nope
nope gary's been snail mapped
[Music]
get ready for the ultimate rescue
mission
in the all-new spongebob movie this is
gonna be like one of those bloody movies
with aquafina you're fired danny trejo
snoop dogg yes boys tiffany haddish
seriously i'm floundering up here
and keanu reeves call me sage
i'm made out of sage and i am a sage so
it works out pretty well
see how the gang all met
[Music]
and experience spongebob's biggest
adventure
sorry every fam
patrick what are you doing free food
[Applause]
the all-new spongebob movie sponge on
the run premiering march 4th rented from
these digital stores also streaming on
paramount plus
[Music]
how's she doing
she barely speaks to me i don't need
your sympathy uncle john
that mustang's got a real mean streak
she's just angry she was rounded up and
taken away from her family
what's her name
i haven't given her a name yet
[Music]
i heard you lost your family too
you really are beautiful
that's what i'll call you black beauty
we've gotten closer to that philly in
days than i have in
weeks they say horses pick you
the rescues have a time limit you can't
sell me
you're my family
you know that right
watch
i promise
[Music]
[Music]
if i fought for every horse i'd ever
loved
out of 100 of them
i don't want 100 horses
i just want one
[Music]
they've taken control of most of europe
and russia
merciful heaven an invasion that's not
all mr president
i take it that's where your big idea
comes in let me introduce you the team
we said we would end this war
too many people have died
we can stop this
we need to utilize every metahuman we
can
who you got there wonder woman
i'm from the future it's not
impossible
are you ready to end this war i thought
you'd never ask then welcome to the team
if this goes haywire blame the new guy
turns out the nazis are launching a
surprise attack then we stop them
mother of god
a kid you ain't seen nothing yet
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
erica you haven't ever wished a family
would adopt you
have you
nope
anybody who choose me would be pretty
unusual
we'll take this one
for the first time in my life i'm being
made to do something i don't want to do
now then let's you and i get a few
things straight my name is bella yaga
i'm a witch great
you agree that you'll teach me magic and
i agree to help you out
if you work really hard i shan't do
anything to hurt you
i love potion for the boy next door all
of these are pretty useless to me
the spell i believe you're looking for
is somewhere towards the back
hang on you actually talk of course i do
just not very often
in this household there's one rule
that's crucial
you must on no account for any reason
ever dare disturb the man drake
don't be rude
a hole left by a witch
[Music]
i'll be learning magic well so i was
told can't wait to start
[Music]
happy birthday mr adult man no mom
what was dad like his beard was scratchy
he had a goofy laugh i wish i'd met him
[Music]
have something for you from your dad
it's a wizard staff
i wrote this spell so i could see for
myself who my boys grew up to be
this spell brings him back back like
back to life he wanted to meet you more
than anything
holy tooth of zadar how did you i don't
know it just started
hang on
dad
stood up bart dad you are in your house
we've only got 24 hours to bring back
the rest of dad
we're going on a quest
all quests start with the manticore the
fearless adventurer you mean corey she's
over there quick somebody help me these
griffin nuggets were supposed to go out
minutes ago that's the man's accord
you guys are in trouble big time get in
the vehicle i'm escorting you home i'm
giving you to the count of three
uh okay wait what are you doing i don't
know
i'm looking for my sons oh they went on
a quest but don't worry i told him about
the map i told him about the gym i told
him about the curse huh i forgot to tell
him about the cars the what
your boys are in great danger
hold on
[Applause]
how are you boys doing a crisis
oh no
we're dead we're dead we're dead not
great
[Applause]
i can't do it we're not gonna see you
dad you can do this i believe in you
my gut knows where to go don't you boy
yes you do
i'm on my way boys just stay out of
trouble
[Music]
you all right back there it's a bumpy
this
this is nothing
i could whip you around again show you
the old loop-de-loop
every family is weird
but trust me mine is the weirdest
my dad is bigfoot what's the next step
clothing line sneaker endorsement video
game deal yes the bigfoot
you wouldn't know it but i'm a bigfoot
too
wow
extract oil puts nature first clean oil
by extract clean oil you've got to be
kidding me with your fame and influence
you can help stop extract before it's
too late
you just got home you can't leave again
what's the point of fame if i don't use
it to make the world a better place
[Music]
need armed guards if they've got nothing
to hide
breaking news bigfoot has gone missing
what he needs our help oh boy here we go
again
hey guys buckle up
so much for no environmental impact
mom dad i'm the hero
together
we're making pancakes hit me
oh shoot trevor don't thank me for your
lousy cats
do you know why you're here to me
mistakes were made
just so you know
whatever you share with me in this room
stays in this room this is a safe space
so no bugs
bugs listening devices
oh no
greetings fellow humans
what you are about to see is a
historical record of my life as a
detective i live in the shadow of this
water tower in portland oregon a place
where things get strange
i am the ceo of my own detective agency
he's so fascinating i can show you
around the precinct sometime i don't
collaborate with law enforcement how
come i have a partner that's cool who's
that his name is total
he's a 1500 pound polar bear
whoa are you serious
mother not now timmy
the failure mobile commands the respect
of others it belongs to my mother who
won it in a church raffle
it was the key to my success until it
was stolen
yeah yeah that was the one nice thing i
had mistakes were made
finding the photomobile is now our top
priority he's fired up today
i know it's so exciting
i need help you always get me into
trouble
can i help you yeah
your life is big
original
weird
so cool
if you love what you do you gotta fight
for it mother i need more office space
my name is failure
the name is misleading because i am
anything but
i am only concerned this one thing
greatness
mistakes were made
[Music]
welcome to
unlock your potential with world famous
magicians
andy duckerman is back baby
hey where are you going how are you i'm
right here it's been too long i thought
you'd given up magic i'm doing private
shows around the world for super
important people whatever my bunk is
gonna beat you just like i did every
summer when we were kids this is
ridiculous
you know what's ridiculous how bad
you're gonna lose
show me what you got this is actually my
first year here
you're all newbies
this is the moment that i disappear in a
puff of smoke
they have zero skills they're hopeless
dude i was just swallowing around
oh i can work with this
[Music]
what if i told you
we have a chance to win the top hat
competition
who's with me if we say yes can we eat
you want to compete against me you're
insane
be prepared for anything
oh i know how you do it
double stick tape
sick burn you teach them that spoiler
alert
i'm just not that good with people
but there's one thing i'm good at
[Music]
mission was to find out what they knew
but that's kind of difficult now that
you killed everyone
i just don't think you're cut out for
the intelligence this is your last shot
how's school going oh my god you have
jelly all over your face i'm definitely
posting that on insta is it too late to
homeschool me
are you cia
how'd you get in oh because she has a
camera she might be streaming if kim
finds out we got made by a nine year old
my career is over what's the option
killer make it look like an accident
yeah maybe the stairs what wow still
recording
we can cut a deal i want you to teach me
how to be a spy just to be clear this is
a one-time arrangement never again i
can't promise so what's first shooting
range obstacle course or to walk away
from an explosion will i detect your
test i can smell a lie endorphins
release an odor in the ultimate tell
slightest blink of an eye anything like
this jj i admire all of your tattoos
stop jj i believe you that you've never
taken steroids
damn she's good
when you look out there what do you see
90 civilians minimal security soft
perimeter smiling people having fun you
should try it sometimes
[Applause]
the objective of this exercise is to get
past me a good idea might be to cause a
distraction because otherwise there'd be
zero chance that you'd be
blue
i'm just like exterior
you're a nice guy
what is he doing
this looks like the wedding at the end
of shrek i just wanna break the rules
in a world
full of hidden danger
one secret team of super spies watches
our tales
please say the password beethoven
incorrect uh scooby doo
garfield you got it sister seriously i
put in a request
[Music]
how was the night shift all dad well
back's a little stiff
ah roast beef
i'm not gonna even ask
what the feline is that
i am the most nefarious villain the
world has ever seen
this is not good
take to the skies boss
we are getting reports of global unrest
developing in the pet world we don't
stop this now it could lead to an
all-out war between cats and dogs
bottom line this starts and ends with
you two
just need a minute
when evil strikes soon they will feel
what it is like to be unwanted
we're gonna need a crew heroes unite is
clyde in 6d he wears a diaper he could
track someone's scent from a mile away
doggy diaper nuff said anastasia leopold
maximus worms fleas explosive diarrhea
and that's just anastasia
we need qualified dependable specialists
are we robbing a casino to catch a
criminal mastermind
breaks breaks breaks oh no a roundabout
maybe
you think it was too much
and never
whoa
oh dear god we're doomed
cats and dogs 3 paws unite
what do they do you should notice your
disdain for one another begin to wear
off oh your coat is so soft
on dvd blu-ray and digital
[Music]
candace every day you call and tell me
phineas and ferb have built some big
unbelievable things and every day i come
home to find nothing there doesn't it
exist you it exhausts me
oh look there's nothing here
okay guys i give up what does this one
do
uh candace
where are you going
where is she going
candace got abducted by aliens and taken
to another planet when we step through
this portal we're gonna be on an alien
planet
hello and welcome aliens
giant robot
he's usually harmless if we're going to
rescue kids we need to build a spaceship
my galactic travelinator
you mean like a spaceship but it's an
anethor there's a difference
it's branding leave me alone
verb i know we're gonna do today
we have to pass through an ion barrier
yeah so
it could fry all of the electronics on
the ship standing us in space
okay that was something i did not know
we need to find where they're keeping
candace
[Music]
i know what we're gonna do today
it's me against the universe
superheroes stand watch when danger
closes in and save those in need
but they have one thing in common
they never show up in the real world
until ulysses
every superhero
comes to us with a purpose
we don't always see it at first
because we don't always know where to
look
[Music]
flora
what is this
i am ulysses
born a new holy unanticipated
occurrences
did you type this
he's a superhero
but
do you have any enemies
i'm here about the squirrel danger lurks
everywhere
is he he's flying
there was a change in the air
and the world
was filling with excitement
hungry
what now come on
people look to the skies for someone to
save them so the universe sent us
[Music]
ulysses
can you talk
okay that's not really talking but still
the yukon is a dangerous place
you never know what's coming
i came up here because i
didn't want to be around anyone
and then i met buck
he was a dog
like no other
you've been spoiled
[Music]
i don't know where you came from but i
know where you are now
welcome to the last place on the earth i
should let him have a minute
doesn't look like he's ever seen snow
before
how do you feel about an adventure
beyond all maps
we could go
you and i
where no one's ever been before
[Music]
see what's out there
[Music]
i'm glad you're enjoying this
i never saw him believe in anything
as much as he believes in you
[Music]
what do you say book
adventure of a lifetime
he was sleeping for two days
in my bed
shall i tell you a story
[Music]
it's the story of an orphan girl
it was sent to live
in a mysterious house if you caused me
trouble i'll have you sent away in an
instant you understand
that she discovered something
something
magical
something
secret
but let me start at the beginning
my name is mary lennox and my uncle owns
this house i'm colin craven and the
uncle you speaking is my father my
cousin
when's the last time you used your chair
i've never been able to walk we could go
outside who knows you might feel
better who are you i'm digging i need
you to keep a secret
on yourself
if you are too much of a lady there is
no
i am no lady sir
[Music]
capable of extraordinary things i'd say
that you're lying do you trust me
you know what you risk
it's worth the risk
magic is on our side
but this house was filled with lights
laughter
happiness
this garden needs to cure colin
your excitement could kill him colin
needs to live this house is
it's beautiful
logic
secrets
[Music]
and
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to your new home
let's give him a great show okay i won
and only
why do they want an angry gorilla anyway
you're a silverback he terrified humans
oh
you're not terrifying
who's that
my sister where's your sister now
i don't remember
memories never leave us
they just get out of reach
whoa did you draw all these a gorilla
who draws
what is it don't tell me don't tell me
it's a lonely haystack on a late summer
day
it's a beetle
can you tell me a story
once there was a baby elephant who was
smart and brave and she needed to live
in the wild where she could be free
[Music]
does the baby elephant get to be free
[Music]
this painting is clearly a sign he wants
to be free
what about mac he's taking care of me my
whole life
we're family
we're in this together
[Music]
i'll just cross the road then why would
you cross the road to get to the other
side
we want to know everything about the man
we work for
the man
oh no this isn't about the father
this is about the sun
heart miss fowl
[Applause]
you've grown strong son
and smarter
than i ever imagined
then take me with you
you're all i have now arty
there's just one very important thing i
have to do
[Music]
authorities launched a worldwide manhunt
for the famous collector he is suspected
to have been behind some of the biggest
robberies ever dad
hello your family has taken something of
great value from us return it to me or i
will destroy everything you love
you weren't supposed to see this yet
your father is in a complicated
profession for years he has protected
powerful secrets that have kept mankind
safe from the dangers of another world
it's time to face your destiny
this is what they call greatness but we
are not alone in this mulch
just a talented giant dwarf and i'm
holly short your ally on the other side
it's real
all right save my father save the world
hope team ready tell them
let's get ahead optimus i'm scared to
death
an army is coming
[Applause]
i'm the next criminal mastermind
look around this is what they call
greatness i didn't read much on trolls
anything i should look out for the teeth
they eat people good to know
this holiday season we're thankful for
the pets whose love got us through the
year
but next year get ready to love
even bigger
[Music]
bye